[Music]
what's going on guys it's almost summer
that means it's just about time for
bikini season and summer movie season
that means it's time for our fifth
annual screen junkies summer box office
predictions
I wonder who won the last one oh yeah I
did pretty proud of that we have a
strong panel of movie Minds who have put
forth their predictions for the top ten
grocers in domestic box office but don't
worry international movie watchers we're
going to be talking about you guys as
well let's meet the folks who are making
our predictions this time around first
you've seen her on screen junkies news
she's part of the YouTube channel hissy
fit and she's also one of the hosts of
the wrestling podcast tights and fights
Daniel Radford hello welcome having me
this guy you know him you'll love the
head writer of screen junkies Spencer
Gilbert Fitz remember hell heck yeah and
this man is the host of Dan's labyrinth
movie fights champion welcome back Dan
Merle good to be here how before we go
any further let's take a look at
everybody's list
here's Dan's list he's the highest on
Despicable Me 3 the lowest on Pirates
dead men tell no tales and he's the only
one to have balerion and the city of a
thousand planets on his list you're
Spencer's list he's the highest on
spider-man homecoming the lowest on
wonder woman and he's the only one to
have both Dunkirk and the emoji movie on
his list
Danielle's list has her the highest on
guardians volume - she's the lowest on
cars three and she's the only one to
have the mummy and The Dark Tower make
her list and here's my list I'm the
highest on Warfel Planet of the Apes the
lowest on Pirates of the Caribbean and
I'm the only one to have Captain
Underpants
and rough night I noticed Dan and myself
both have Despicable Me 3 as number one
Spencer Danielle why are you picking the
wrong movie at number one I think if
they caught me is going to do good it's
still on my list but I also think that
people might just be a little minion
doubt for a while so I'd still on my
list but
not quite as high as else I'm going to
take this in a slightly different
direction I think not enough minions
that's the only time you'll hear me say
that raised out loud but not enough
minions because the trailer didn't have
enough minions in it so a lot of morons
are going to be confused like where's
the menu here's the difference though
both of your arguments have to do with
discerning audiences and here's the
thing kids don't care it has a minion on
it it has a minion in it they're going
to go see it the last two summers I fall
into the trap of picking the Marvel
movie as the number one movie this year
I think we saw last year with finding
dory
just how well kids movies can do and
don't forget with a kids movie you're
not selling one ticket you selling two
tickets Spencer and Danielle did not
have Despicable Me at the top of their
list Spencer had spider-man homecoming
Danielle had guardians volume to fight
it out I think that spider-man you know
on its own a top five movie but they're
billing this is kind of a Spider Man
Iron Man buddy movie and whether that's
what it actually is or not
that's how it's being sold spider-man's
gonna do great because it's spider-man
but it's also we've had so many
spider-man movies there's a lot of
Spider Men I think people are going to
go see it I just don't see it being a
mad rush to the theater for this new
gotcha but you do have it at number two
so I do have a number two I think it's
going to do well I just don't think it's
gonna top Guardian mm-hmm yeah Dan you
have guardians at number two guardians
to I think that it's going to make a lot
of money but you know early review so
far I've indicated that it's good maybe
not as good as the first one that might
depress the viewership a little bit and
yeah with spider-man actually I was
looking at the numbers and every success
of spider-man movie even going back to
the Tobey Maguire one has made less
money than the last one I am the highest
on war for Planet of the Apes that's I
have that come in at number four the
other movies have really performed in
the summer and I feel like this a
franchise people are excited for
Danielle you don't have it on your list
any thoughts it's such a crowded field
this summer I think that if it was not a
summer movie it would do great I mean
the last one had a monkey on a freaking
horse with double guns going through a
fireball yeah amazing again if it was
any other time of year I think that it
would do it would do better but I don't
I don't see it you're right there's
there is a lot to choose from I will
agree with you on that crowded field
we all have transformers the last night
on our list people will pay to see this
movie it's you know Michael Bay makes a
big a sex-driven spectacle turn off your
brain go to the theater spencer's the
highest at number five gambling on your
boy Bay it's a safe bet always bet on
Bay
always bet on Bay let's talk about
another franchise that may have seen its
peak and is now trying to squeeze a
little more blood from that stone
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales i'm lowest on it at number ten
dan is also pretty low at number eight
i'm hi whoa
you got that stuff at number four
Antigua happens number six we have yes a
talk to me about your love of Johnny
Depp and all things Pirates of the
Caterine love is a strong word but I
rely on that Disney machine to get
rolling and to just put Johnny Depp's
face as Jack Sparrow which I think still
has currency there getting the gang back
together it looks like they put some
effort into this one and it has been I
think like five six years since the last
pirates movie that no one saw I think
we're ready to stick it again I think
this is going to be the biggest divide
you see this summer between domestic box
office and international box office
because I think this movie is going to
crush the international box office
domestically
I'm not sure how it's going to do gotcha
interesting interesting Dan um it looks
like you're the only one with valerian
and the city of a thousand planets on
your list I have that is my gamble I
know what I said when Matt Matt with
fury road came out I regretted not
putting it on my list and a based off of
a trailer that looked great and I said
oh I wish I had the guts to put Mad Max
on my list but I just can't it looks too
weird it looks too different everything
that I said about Mad Max applies to
valerian in the city of a thousand
planets especially with Lucas on
directing this movie could be awful this
movie could be Jupiter ascending yes but
it could be Mad Max fury road Mad Max
fury road had Tom Hardy and Charlize
Theron this one has Cara Delevingne
that's why I'm saying it's not a
slam-dunk it's not okay but I had to put
something that looked original on my
list you're tapping into something that
I felt when I was compiling my list
because when you're putting it okay up
money
a cash cow like it's not good for the
soul
you want a movie that's like what brings
you a little joy some something unique I
will make a side bet with you that there
is no way valerian makes in the top 10
movies now a movie that I don't have on
my list but Dan does have on his list
and Danielle also has is Baywatch and
you're the highest on Baywatch yeah
you're betting on the rock huh and on
the rock mm-hmm I think the rock is a
solid bet obviously people love that
dude yeah and it's just you know it's a
nice goofy summer comedy people like him
people like basically every all the
actors are in that movie so it's not
just the rock it's also the fact that is
just such a big broad goofy comedy
Spencer you are the lowest on wonder
woman why do you hate women look Wonder
Woman looks like a well-made movie it's
going to get a lot of DC fanboys and
really compact as two out there to see
it mm-hmm I don't know why I'm so low on
it compared to you why are you guys so
high on it when the woman is an iconic
character yeah this is her first movie
it looks really good and it looks
different from all the other DC movies I
know a lot of people are kind of hanging
their hopes that this is going to be
where DC turns it around for people who
are not so into the DC movies Plus don't
discount women I know folks who are
already like I don't care I'm buying
free tickets because they need to know
that if you make a movie with a woman
lead a superhero movie we will support
that movie that's an interesting point I
think it's a point not to be taken for
granted of the whole Batman V Superman
debacle the one thing that everyone
almost unanimously agreed on was that
Wonder Woman was great okay a movie we
all have on our list cars three Spenser
number two uh yeah I think that this is
a four-quadrant picture you know man
woman child what do you do most days
yeah get in the car or you see a car and
they see that up on the movie theater
and they go car I know that word and
then they see the movie
you sold me on that except what are the
four quadrants man woman child uh uh
Holy Ghost
there you go okay dad you got a number
three here you I came just like John
Lasseter today to celebrate part three
yeah Pixar's not laughing wearing a
Hawaiian generic
don't leave I not a little little color
ya know I think the cars three is you
know Pixar is always big during the
summer cars is probably the lesser of
all of their franchises box office wise
but it's the still make money and I
think for some reason I think it's that
first trailer this movie strangely has a
little bit of buzz around it Danielle
you went rogue on a couple of choice
hahaha you have a couple of things on
your list that none of us have picked
first I want to ask you about the mummy
that dude opens movies Tom Cruise I'm
still open moving on to watch and he's
fun to watch and it's got everything you
need he's running there's just a bunch
of Tom Cruise running but one movie that
I would be pretty surprised if it made
it that you have coming in at number 10
Dark Tower
it is a beloved Stephen King epic and
it's kind of like this gothic western
type thing great cast people are huge
huge fans of Stephen King huge fans of
that series and they've been waiting for
this movie for years for being such a
known property I feel like still a
little under the radar with all the
bright lights of the summer contenders
well yeah I've very skeptical about Dark
Tower I just think the combination of is
it gonna police fans is it going to
convert newcomers I just don't know if
it's going to do either Spencer I want
to talk about a couple of your outliers
that none of us have you're gambling on
the Christopher Nolan war epic Dunkirk
yeah I mean it looks great but will it
have box office legs in the summertime
usually one prestige movie sneaks in
there horse thieves Nolan oh I think
that usually one of these one sneaks in
right I thought that with the emoji boom
yup and then we're the only one to put
the emoji movie Spencer get them out of
here yeah well I'm getting the reality
bad movies do well all the time people
are on their phones more than they're
talking to each other and they're smiley
face smiley face hula girl of eggplant
is not going to make the top ten box off
it is mark my words Patrick Stewart is a
piece of literally and you're going to
pay to see him a knight of the kingdom
is going to do G - I had on my list that
no one else had I gambled on Captain
Underpants
because again just like Dan said you
can't just have one ticket sold multiple
tickets sold I feel like it's a popular
franchise with kids
it'll fill some seats and uh the
female-driven comedy rough night it's a
movie that I really want to see and I
think it could surprise and you always
very often you have a comedy sneak in
there and not just a comedy but a
female-driven comedy has a tradition of
cracking the top ten of the heat crack
the top ten rise may be bridesmaids
crack the top ten as derided as it was
the movie that we shall not speak about
from last summer that caused so much
controversy crack a because late oh yeah
movie so that's more or less an overview
of our lists and by the way we do
domestic because a well speaking for
myself we are ugly Americans and be just
as far as release dates and everything
it just makes it a little bit easier to
be too many checks and balances to
figure out if we incorporate all
box-office but we don't want to leave
out international because we love our
fans all over the world and we want you
to feel included so our tiebreaker is
the number one internationally grossing
film of the summer so um let's start
with Danielle my pick you're going to be
guardians of the galaxy I know that it's
very joke heavy and sometimes that can
be a problem when it comes to
translations and stuff but I think that
there is just enough brightly colored
things and aliens and explosions plus
it's a Marvel movie that that'll that'll
make a difference Spencer what do you
got you know what everyone in the world
does they drive cars you don't need to
speak English to drive a car last I
checked I think this translates
worldwide because it's for kids it's for
adults maybe and you really don't need
to understand anything about the world
in which we live to appreciate a movie
about a car that's alive we'll leave it
at that
dan I'm going with the movie that's
actually number seven on my domestic
list well number one international
Transformers the last night I think it's
going to be lowered in the charts in the
u.s. I think it is going to explode and
make a billion dollars or more worldwide
I chose transformers as my number one
well movie I'm gonna go with Oh always
bet on yellow the menu
oh let's go is a Despicable Me 3 well
there you have it those are our list
what do you think of them let us know in
the comments section below and wait a
second we want you to compete too
because every year we have the fans
compete and we read the winners right
here on the show so are you ready for
this compile your list and go to SJ dot
plus slash box-office 2017 that's SJ dot
plus slash box-office 2017 let us know
what your top ten list will be for the
summer the details for the contest are
in the description below oh boy Daniel
Radford thank you for making your first
appearance on the screen junkie show you
guys think so much for having me out
great having you Spencer Gilbert always
good to see you my friend Dan Morelle
we'll see what happens and I want to
thank you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye-bye